Trump and Biden are tied nationally
right now new poll out this is by New
York Times Siena College so you can't
call it a conservative poll Trump Biden
43-43 the breakdown is much more
interesting than the Top Line National
numbers Trump is leading among white
voters by 10 points it's a decent lead
Biden is leading among black voters by
59 points Biden is leading among
Hispanic voters by three points the
other interesting aspect when we break
this down is that Trump has more support
among his base than Biden has among his
Trump in a huge field with 10 candidates
has more support in the GOP than Joe
Biden who is the incumbent and
theoretically should be running on a
post he's got Bobby Kennedy's running
against him then Biden has as an
incumbent among his space really really
pathetic for Biden and really bad news
for the other GOP candidates